good morning Hank it's Tuesday my friend
and Mentor Bill Ott died last week bill
was the publisher of book list magazine
for more than 30 years he was my first
boss he was a brilliant writer and
editor and a wonderful friend and also
as readers of the anthropocene reviewed
may know he kind of Saved My Life One
time I know some of y'all have heard
that story but I want to tell it again
in Bill's memory so in late 2001 I had a
mental health crisis and my depression
got so bad that in consultation with my
parents it was decided that I needed to
quit my job and move home to Florida to
get full-time care and so one morning I
went into Bill's office now he was the
publisher of the magazine he was my
boss's boss's boss there were proof
pages of the Magazine spread out all
over his desk I've worked there less
than two years like any normal boss
would have been like it's so great to
have worked with you I'm sorry you're
going through this and I really wish you
well but instead he said ah kid and then
he paused Bill had serious speech
challenges as a kid and as an adaptation
he developed these masterful pauses so
that you were always just leaning
forward when he delivered the punch line
or some brilliant observation and so
after that long pause he said why don't
you just take some time off and let us
know how you're feeling in a few weeks
later when I was packing up my stuff to
leave book list I found that Bill had
left a note on my computer I still have
that note it ends now more than ever
watch Harvey which was this movie he
loved that he wanted me to see and it
turned out that he wanted me to see it
for a reason because it is about
somebody living with serious mental
illness who nonetheless is valuable and
important and worthy I got better I went
back to work I was able to review
hundreds more books and then eventually
wrote my own book under the guidance of
Bill's wife the great children's book
author Eileen Cooper that book Looking
for Alaska went on to win the prince
award and when I accepted that Award
with a speech bill was there and he came
up to me afterwards and he was I really
liked your speech kid except for that
stuff about morality that was really our
only long-standing disagreement over
whether stories had some kind of moral
or ethical responsibility to their
readers they'll maintained that a
novel's job was to be good and true and
I maintained that in order to be true a
novel had to be hopeful and Redemptive
which Bill thought was a bunch of
hogwashing that novels needed hope like
fish need bicycles and I just loved
having those big conversations with Bill
because he was so much older and wiser
than me but he still took me seriously
and because he seemed to have read
everything he taught me to love mystery
novels and old movies and he taught me
about Precision in writing how the
second best word simply won't suffice
but here's the biggest thing I learned
from Bill he loved his work and he was
passionate about it but the love of his
life was not book list or even books it
was people he loved his wife Eileen with
whom he shared the most profound
connection and the most uproarious humor
he loved his daughter so much and he
loved his his grandson like when I
picture bill I don't think of him
reading or editing I think of the way
his face lit up when he had a story to
tell me about his kid Bill taught me
that work matters and stories matter but
nothing matters like people do if you've
benefited from my work in any way you've
also benefited from Bill's work and I
know many writers who would say the same
I mean there's a good chance that if you
love a book Bill wrote or edited one of
the early reviews that helped that book
get to more people for me that's both
the Heartbreak and the hope of human
life everything goes everything except
for the love we pour into others and
into the world I'm so grateful for the
love Bill shared with me and I hope he
knew how much I admired him and how
desperately I will miss him
Hank I'll see you on Friday